et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
donc patrick mennucci bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous membres du
bureau national du parti socialiste à
porte parole dan d'algos dans cette
campagne et on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale avec depuis votre ville de
marseille guilhem rica vie bonjour
guilhem merci d'être avec nous directeur
des rédactions jour de la provence
guilhem on va évidemment parler la
présidentielle avec vous patrick
mennucci vous avez été rappelés dans
cette campagne vous l'historique du
parti socialiste on se souvient de vous
au côté de ségolène royal c'était
pendant la campagne de 2007 votre retour
celui de bernard cazeneuve également ça
montre qu'il ya le feu au lac dans la
campagne d'algues au nom jour je pense
que ça montre qu' il y a rassemblement
autour d'anne hidalgo de la grande
majorité de du du parti socialiste et
moi c'est pour moi une
joie de pouvoir refaire une campagne
électorale avec une personnalité aussi
intéressante qu'anne hidalgo au moment
où c'est difficile pour le parti
socialiste mais aussi comme l'a dit
bernard cazeneuve samedi dernier en
prenant la présidence du comité de
soutien d'anne hidalgo ses amis les
géants qui ont
leur idée chevillée au corps mais on les
voit qu'un comme c'est difficile et
voilà pourquoi on est là je vais me
poser la question qui était en une du
parisien aujourd'hui en france hier vous
l'avez sans doute vu c'est une anne
hidalgo pour porter mais c'est une
question qui est
posée sempiternellement et je pense qu'à
un moment la presse va se lasser de la
poser et peut-être même que ça sera pas
plus vendeur de journaux dont comme
arrêter la peau
je vois pas l'intérêt jouera pas les
intérêts de continuer à poser cette
question si ce n'est pour essayer
d'installer un storytelling quelque
chose de vendeurs pour la presse c'est
anne hidalgo
jamais cette questions qu'ils ont posées
sur les manches et jamais quand je fais
la campagne est que je suis anne hidalgo
je ne nomme pas
aucun électeur de gauche dire cela par
contre ce que j'ai constaté hier c'est
qu'il ya six ans
82 maires élus qui ont donné leur
pouvoir de se présenter a ni la lourde
conséquence ionel l'a constaté anne
hidalgo et président république donc
j'espère que maintenant elle est là
ce nombre 1 signatures alors qu'on voit
que d'autre qu'un il a qui prétend aller
a prise depuis quatre ans m chacun
comprendra que anne hidalgo est
candidate et moi personnellement je n'ai
d'ailleurs j'ai mis tout
ça
veut dire qu'elle est légitime
aujourd'hui je parle pas de légitimité
il ya des lois dans ce pays la loi celle
et les maires et les élus habilité qui
donne
et c'est à la fin qu'on boit si vous
avez le droit de vous présenter ou pas
la question plutôt qui est posée sur
lesquels la diversité des candidatures
c'est que je crois qu'il y a une chose
qui est clair c'est que anne hidalgo est
la seule à incarner dans ce concert la
gauche de gouvernement donc la question
que nous allons faire émerger chez les
français que nous poussons pour que les
français comprennent c'est qu'il y a une
candidate qui représente qui reliés à
l'histoire et au contenu de ce que les
socialistes ont fait comme s'il était au
pouvoir que ce soit ce qu'a fait
françois hollande que ce soit ce qu'a
fait françois mitterrand ou lionel
jospin ces animaux et pour le reste il
s'agit
généralement d'une façon de faire de la
politique et qui ne prend pas en compte
le réel or anne hidalgo sa particularité
c'est qu'elle est à la fois pour
l'égalité mais elle est aussi pour
l'économie de marché elle est pour pour
une fausse réguler mais elle n'est pas
pour le grand n'importe quoi comme le
voyage chez d'autres candidats de gauche
donc je pense que ça c'est extrêmement
important
parce que vous parlez des gens
qui ne
rient fectivement parce que quand on
regarde le parti socialiste il y avait
historiquement deux sections qui avaient
un poids particulier la section du nord
est et celle des bouches du rhône le
premier fédéral du nord a fait savoir
qu'il ne soutiendrait pas anne hidalgo
non à paillant bas est plutôt discret
sur la question ne la soutient pas vous
patrick mennucci le marseillais vous
avez parlait benoît payante cette
question alors j'ai eu besoin de payer
en il ya une quinzaine de jours on
essaie t dans d'autres circonstances et
on n'a pas pu parler de ça mais ce que
je veux vous dire d'abord c'est que vous
n'avez toujours pas vu la signature du
maire de marseille ont levé par le
conseil constitutionnel
et je crois que vous le savez bien tu es
là se tiendra chez je sais pas mais je
supporte pas la nina goût et donc pas de
bol en payant même si j'ai de bonnes
relations avec lui et que j'ai japon va
parfaitement stable politiquement
ces réseaux c'est un problème pour le
parti socialiste mais ce qui est clair
c'est que mais j aimerais qu à vie le
sait mieux que moi c'est que la majorité
municipale de benon père n'est pas une
mini si une majorité municipale le parti
socialiste est majoritaire de gaulle et
tout le monde me connaît les
circonstances
de la date de l'accession du maire de
man c'est au pouvoir et donc je pense
que le maire de vence et essaye de bien
faire les choses pour sa ville et c'est
je crois que la personne la plus
importante aujourd'hui pour blancpain
c'est ce qu'il fait avec l'état et les
milliards que
l'état essayé de donner à marseille pour
régler la calamiteuse gestion du jeune
congolais plus importante c'est emmanuel
macron plus qu'animé n'ont rien à perdre
mais madame nous parlons de dés des
subventions qui sont donnés aux écoles
marseillaise penser que la maire de
paris peut donner
je réponds que la queue en payant à une
problématique de maire d'une ville qui
est en grande difficulté
il a une majorité extrêmement
hétéroclites et pour lui au problème
c'est l'état parce que c'est l'état
qu'il est donc voilà c'est ça la
question de la ville de man c mais très
honnêtement ce n'est pas avec le maire
de marseille de ce fait la campagne des
présidentielles et nous attendrons de
voir exactement quelle est sa position
que les punks ans puisqu'on a appris
hier il y avait des discussions qui
étaient en cours entre yannick jadot et
christiane taubira est ce qu a encore
des discussions qui sont en cours
aujourd'hui entre amis des lourds mais
mais anne hidalgo elle n'est pas dans
une situation de discuter les candidates
elle a un programme unique ce dossier je
voulais je voulais apporter il est là
c'est le brome d'anne hidalgo je vous
conseille de le de le lire de le revoir
et il est sérieux c'est un programme
pour le pays qui englobe la totalité
épreuves de français après les micmacs 6
ou et à la suite de la primaire
populaire il kiss cool et je commente
les jeunes se rencontrent dans le secret
ils se font taper sur les doigts par son
vrai nom saut parce qu elle que des
hommes dans la réunion j'en sais rien
nous ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
nous sommes en campagne électorale que
nous avons des questions politiques et
si vous voulez mais on pourrait te
parler
des question de programme qui me
paraissent calmer les choses et quand
même c'est important aussi ces questions
de candidature est ce que si toute fois
yannick jadot et christiane taubira
salle et ça va pas poser un problème à
une dalle go qui du coup va apparaître
comme la vie ou des nounous nous ne
sommes pas là j'ai entendu que les
l'hypothèse avait été soulignée et j'ai
aussi entendu la réponse des intéressés
il n'y a pas d'accord donc je veux dire
on ouvre les mois mais les bons été
refermé hier au cours de la conférence
de presse est la question centrale n'est
pas d'ailleurs un accord des candidats
mais c'est que les que les électeurs se
reconnaissent dans le programme vous
croyez que rajouter deux candidats en
additionnant depuis la gauche est à 26
27% qui est trop candidate quatre
candidats ou cinq candidats donc on voit
bien que c'est à l'intérieur de la même
famille politique quelque chose se passe
dont la question peut être réglée d'une
part par l'obtention des signatures et
d'autre part par la compréhension de ce
que sont les problèmes politiques et de
ce point de vue nous avons une grande
confiance à ilo pour le programme de
d'anne hidalgo
oui effectivement on parle de
personnalités de candidatures à gauche à
une personnalité qui semblent progresser
rapidement ces derniers jours c'est
celle de fabien roussel pour le parti
communiste
il faut compter avec lui les sondages le
donnent devant peut-être même anne
hidalgo il aurait fallu l'intégrer là
aussi dans une dans une primaire pour
pourquoi pas permettre aux électeurs
socialistes de le choisir si vous avez
raison si nous avions eu des réponses
favorables
proposition daniel naud qui était
d'organiser une primaire avec la gauche
qui veut gouverner et la question se
serait posé avec le parti gaulliste mais
les réponses ont été ont été non on voit
bien que fabien hausse elle poursuit
dans cette affaire-là une opération de
maintien du parti communiste ça fait
deux fois qu'on parti loin ce n'est pas
candidat il fait une comme banios et
nous verrons à la fin mais est ce que on
pourrait arrêter de commenter les
sondages ou de se commander soi même je
préférerais guy aymeric avis que vous me
disiez ce qu'on pensait dans une ville
comme marseille où le taux de pauvreté
et vous le savez est à 30% de la
population ce qu'on vous pensez la
proposition d'anne hidalgo de porter le
smig à 1400 à fond voilà moi je crois
que ça les questions qui intéressent les
français il faut maintenant qu'on passe
à la campagne électorale la pré campagne
se termine
le blé les acteurs sont en place et
maintenant qu'est ce qu'ils disent
qu'est ce qu'ils proposent
c'est un problème démocratique mais la
question c'est que tout le monde le sait
qu'il est candidat et son programme on
le connaît il y avait regardé ce qu'il a
fait pendant cinq ans et elle va me
proposer autre chose mais moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est est ce que on peut
discuter
par exemple de la question des salaires
est ce qu'on peut alors qu'on vient
d'entamer j'ai compté sur vos antennes
ce matin les questions de pouvoir
d'achat et la province a fait un antique
d hier là dessus et sur les questions de
voir des chiens est ce que on combat les
propositions des candidats la limitation
par exemple laquelle à la proposition de
mme anne hidalgo de limiter deux heures
avait là l'écart des salaires ça c'est
des propositions mais savoir si x ou y
est les signatures ou pas écouté
attendons nous verrons ce que nous
dirons le conseil constitutionnel il y
avait une proposition d'anne delvaux qui
ceva a marqué dans la campagne c'est le
doublement du salaire des enseignants
aujourd'hui elle est revenue dessus
est-ce que c'est du coup ça n'apparaît
pas comme un recul est aujourd'hui
quelle est la proposition forte qui
marque dans la campagne moi je crois
qu'en matière de deux ports d'achat la
halle et je viens de vous les voulez
donner c'est à dire on me passe 18
2268 de 9 euros à presque 1500 si les
autres candidats de gauche
- si vous avez remarqué par exemple
peut-être propre au style mais la vérité
c'est que nous savons avec le parti
socialiste que c'est faisable parce que
le parti socialiste a gouverné il y a
des exemples dans le temps dans
l'histoire de la revalorisation des
salaires par les gouvernants socialiste
soit lionel jospin qui que ce soit avant
même les premiers ministres de françois
mitterrand donc ça nous on existe il ya
je crois aussi ce qui est très important
c'est la limitation des écarts salariaux
et la proposition de 1 avait non pas que
cette imitation soit
impossible puisque tu m avais ça fait
sur une entreprise où la moyenne des
salaires serait de 2000 au havre bien
même que le salaire le plus important
peut être à 40000 mais je trouve que
l'intérêt de cette proposition c'est que
quand le patron voudra surmonter il sera
obligé d'augmenter salariés parce que il
ne pourra pas à ce moment-là dépasser le
cadre du 1 à 20 et je trouve que là
c'est une proposition d'anne hidalgo qui
est extrêmement intéressant parce qu'on
voit notamment dans toutes les grandes
entreprises que les paroles les patrons
n'ont aucun scrupule à se faire d
augmentation de 10% à l'année sans
augmenter leurs salariés donc voir par
exemple d'une proposition sur le pouvoir
d'achat de la candidate socialiste qui
est une proposition parfaitement
dans la dans la logique de la de la
gauche républicaine française social
démocrate et qui peut s'appliquer et
voilà c'est ça la commode écologie sur
l'école je pense qu'il a le goût est ce
que là il n'ya pas aussi une volonté de
la part d'anne hidalgo de montrer
qu'elles allaient dans l'écologie
plusieurs réel et de faire passer les
écologistes les verts europe écologie
les verts pour des écologistes un peu
plus promoteur mme écologie punitive
neutre sur la question de carburant j'ai
jamais entendu exprimer les choses de
votre façon mais si vous en tirer cette
conséquence si qu'il faut regarder mais
il me sens différent il me semble
la différence majeure entre anne hidalgo
et tous les autres sauf le président la
république qui lui est au pouvoir c'est
que à niveau dans une ville comme paris
qui est quand même la première ville
française a mis en place des éléments de
transition écologique elle l'a fait
jeudi aujourd'hui il suffit de d'être
parisien ou d'être touristes à paris on
de venir travailler à paris pour se
rendre compte de la limitation de la
place de la voiture dans la ville et
puisque honnête avec im ray kelly on
peut voir par exemple que la ville de
marseille regardez ce que fait la ville
de paris aujourd'hui pour notamment les
pistes cyclables et faire des choses
identiques et anne hidalgo elle est dans
la réalité de l'écologie de l'écologie
de gouvernement municipal mais qui peut
devenir l'écologie de gouvernement
oui on prend l'exemple justement 2 2
marseille anne hidalgo la parisienne est
ce que vous pensez question peut-être un
peu naïve que d'être maire de paris soit
pas un frein pour des électeurs
marseillais des bouches du rhône je les
ai raison parce que c'est une question
de type équipiers qui qui revient qui
peut être poser
je vais vous dire moi ce que j'ai dit un
italo sur cette question puisque je suis
mort seillier et que j'ai même si
aujourd'hui je vis à paris j'ai cette
ville chevillée au corps je pense que
on est trop dans la pudeur sur la
qualité de la gestion parisienne et je
pense qu'on devrait au contraire montrer
ce que la gestion parisienne a de bien
par rapport à ce qu'il arrive comme
d'autres villes je vous dis moi j'ai un
petit garçon de 9 ans il allait à
l'école amorcé le jeu pas du tout
expliqué ce qui avait commencé le
taillan et d'autre et la provence ont
très souvent retracer les difficultés
économiques mais quand je regarde
comment l'école publique est traitée à
paris combien il y a deux salariés de la
municipalité qui sont là au service des
hommes femmes comme un air de fête in
hier mais je vous dis aussi dans le pays
entier on avait la qualité de la gestion
parisienne municipal je crois que ce
serait une bonne chose et pour la propos
pour la propreté nous via un petit somme
marseillais ont peu de temps et un
sourire quand on voit ces hashtag
saccage paris parce que moi je vous
avoue que vivait à paris je considère
vivre dans la ville plus propre dans
laquelle je n'ai jamais vécu étant resté
37 ans est un élu 37 ans au conseil
municipal devant c'est donc dur parce
que cette question là il faut la
valoriser c'est à dire que ça doit pas
être à long terme om psg permettez moi
mais ça doit être en termes de qualité
de gestion et annie d'amour comme maire
de paris a fait ses preuves
c'est bien normal mais est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui le meilleur candidat de
la gauche non c'est pas emmanuel macron
le meilleur cas ni la gauche c'est une
fête mais vous le faites exprès c'est
une confusion médias emmanuel macron à
40 c où 46% des électeurs ne françois
hollande qui votent pour lui oui c'est
notre faute si si c'est ça c'est parce
qu'avec des questions de la
social-démocratie delà de la gauche
républicaine ne sont pas écartés ou
n'ont pas été une gardé suffisamment
pendant les cinq dernières années c'est
à saint benoît avec le programme d'eau
gelée me parlait d' anne hidalgo nous
comme bateau parce que
fatah qui met à l'ensemble des
socialistes c'est la faute à jouer pas
je vérifierai pommery comme l'a fait
bernard cazeneuve j'aime pas ma part et
chacun se reconnaîtra mais la question
pour nous aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya
urgence il ya ce sont trois jours avant
l'élection c'est de montrer à ses
électeurs que l'acquis d'abord on est
deuxièmes premier tour on n'est pas dans
une deuxième tour et que dans un premier
tour qui me paraît essentiel que la
gauche républicaine celle qui a gouverné
le pays avec mitterrand avec hollande
avec jospeh soient bien représentés dans
cette élection municipale nous parler de
pouvoir d'achat c'est normal c'est la
passion majeure des français on parle
d'écologie mais il ya aussi des
questions qui inquiètent les français à
l'immigration est ce que les socialistes
n'ont pas mis la poussière sous le tapis
sur ces questions pendant des années ce
qui pourrait
alors je pose c'est que là il ya des
témoins et marseillais enfin les joies
et est considéré comme quelqu'un
d'extrêmement sécuritaires avancées mais
bon je crois pas du tout ça je crois que
là il ya une confusion entre la façon
dont notre s'exprimer le respect qu'on
peut avoir pour les sans papiers pour
les immigrés pour les jambes les ports
qui arrivent sur des bateaux et le
respect de la légalité républicaine ce
sont deux choses différentes mais ce qui
concerne la mise à l'eau il n'y a aucune
demande cette affaire-là de laxisme
aucunement
oui patrick mennucci je vous ramène de
nouveau à marseille parce qu'on a bien
vu ces derniers jours dans la cité
phocéenne des élus les républicains et
bien claqué la porte de leur parti pour
rejoindre emmanuel macron le dernier en
date et il s'exprime d'air dans les
colonnes de la provence ce matin c'est
lionel royer perreaut merdes secteur que
vous avez côtoyé qui dit non je ne veux
pas de valérie pécresse non je ne veux
pas d'une certaine façon non plus de ce
que pouvait faire martine vassal et donc
je rejoins et emmanuel macron vous
l'expliquez comment cette désertion il
abu plusieurs cas ces derniers jours on
en annonce d'autres cette désertion de
la droite marseillaise pour rejoindre
emmanuel macron jeu je pense d'abord
lionel royer perreaut il fait une drôle
chemin gars vraiment puisque il vient du
front national
je crois qu'il était l'assistant
parlementaire de feu la député yann piat
donc nous avons là quelqu'un qui a
commencé chez fasciste et qui finit chez
emmanuel macron au fond pour la
démocratie tant mieux et je dois dire
que je connais royer perreaut ces
dernières années il avait complètement
évolué et hausse était de maire
d'arrondissement puisque j'étais en même
temps que lui dans cette fonction avec
qui on pourrait parfaitement discuté
aujourd'hui je me suis dit oui je suis
toujours en train de commenter des
choses qui m'intéressent pas parce que
je n'ai pas la campagne mais je le fais
parce que je dois à la province de
répondre puisque je continue je rassure
guillet mal à lire tous les jours
je pense qu'il y a l'hallali déchets et
royer perreaut que s'il veut le jour
être candidat à la mairie de marseille
et nous savons que c'est son objectif il
faut qu'il trouve une famille politique
pour le faire or la famille de droite
elle est occupée par martine vassal et
la famille de gauche par benoît paillard
donc je crois qu'il est en train de
chercher moi où il va pouvoir construire
sa candidature et c'est vrai que c'est
quelqu'un qui a des qualités des
gestionnaires et c'est sans doute un
coup rude qui est donnée à la présidence
de la métro pour le mans ces cinq années
un dernier mot pour les lecteurs
je leur dis que d'abord il y à deux
tours dans une élection et koné dans
l'élection de premier tour et que il me
semble que ce qui est important pour
l'avenir c'est que la gauche qu'ils
aiment à celle qu'ils ont connue avec
mitterrand et moi avec hollande parce
que peut-être la faute que a fait le
parti suisse puisque vous en parlez
terre c'était d'avoir une vision du du
quinquennat hollande absolument
politique oh ce n'est pas l'avis des
débiles des français dit tout fin de ce
kilos soutenu il y en a beaucoup et
aujourd'hui ils soutiennent emmanuel
macron mais il faut leur dire que les
orientations ne fera le saut l'homme
notamment elles sont touchées anne
hidalgo se retrouve pas chez emmanuel
macron donc voilà c'est ça qui dit qu'il
va s'exprimer dans louis à s'exprimer
non c'est un problème pour vous
mais moi je suis absolument favorable à
ce que tous ceux qui comme
françois hollande ou bernard cazeneuve
sont pour partie de la famille
socialiste soutienne lundi d'allouer
d'ailleurs ce matin j'ai écouté sur une
autre chaîne stéphane le foll gtoi
extrêmement élégant dans la façon de
s'exprimer qui a réaffirmé ce soutien à
anne hidalgo même si il a des
problématiques et le parti séisme mais
je pense qu'on n'est pas en train de
faire une congrès du parti socialiste on
est en train d'essayer de désigner le
président français
mais on n est pas là et puis le congrès
ça intéressant les militants socialistes
la scène tu as tous les français et moi
je leur dis vraiment avec conviction la
personne qui est adaptée at président de
la république cette année
[Musique]